et on retrouve à Kiev notre
correspondant Guliver crack bonjour à
vous Guliver on en sait un peu plus sur
ces explosions qui ont retenti ce matin
à l'aube il s'agit de tir de missiles
russes selon le chef de la diplomatie
oui je pense que c'est la continuation
de ce qu'ils ont commencé à faire hier à
cette voix tirer avec tes missiles de
longue distance pour le moment il semble
que les cibles sont des cibles
militaires mais uniquement je me permets
de vous interrompre Gulliver pas
uniquement on apprend à l'instant en
tout cas de par la voix du président
ukrainien que les que les forces russes
visent aussi des zones civiles donc ce
n'est plus seulement des bases
militaires qui sont visées
non ce n'est pas sûr le président
ukrainien dit ça mais peut-être que il
vit des stibs militaires mais il frappe
des zones civiles par erreur c'est comme
ça que c'est la Harry d'ailleurs il y a
un bâtiment résidentiel à Kiev qui est a
été touché c'est là qu'il y a au moins
trois blessés oui blessés selon
certaines informations mais il semble
que c'est quand un missile soit un avion
les informations sont contradictoires
russes a été abattu par les Ukrainiens
donc on comprend bien qu'ils vont
essayer de Tabattre ces missiles et ses
avions mais il est possible aussi que
c'est pour cela que le missile n'a pas
atteint son cible si vous voulez c'est
plus compliqué que cela on n'a pas
l'impression en tout cas pour le moment
qu'il y a une stratégie délibérée de
cibler des cibles en
Ukraine ou du moins à Kiev pour le
moment ça va cela ne veut pas dire que
ça va pas arriver dans les heures ou
dans les jours qui viennent mais pour le
moment on en est pas là et je vais
entendre des tirs encore assez loin
pense pas mais je sais pas où est-ce que
c'était encore des tirs domicile quel
serait les conséquences on en parlait
avec gauthierrybinsky tout à l'heure si
les forces russes parvenaient à
s'emparer de Kia est-ce que ce scénario
est envisagé ici en Ukraine où vous vous
trouvez
oui c'est absolument le scénario qui est
envisagé c'est absolument ce que
craignent toutes les habitants de Kiev
la plupart des Ukrainiens et quand on
sait que les forces russes sont à
hostome une aérodrome a 10 km du
centre-ville apparemment la bataille
pour le contrôle de cette aérodrome
continue et il n'est pas sûr que les
Russes réussissent à s'accaparer de
l'aérodrome définitivement mais ils se
sont accaparés de la centrale nucléaire
l'axe centrale nucléaire si vous voulez
de Tchernobyl qui est à 2h de route de
Kiev seulement au nord et il commence à
arriver par le nord-est aussi il y a
cette bataille autour de la grande ville
du nord-est soumis apparemment ils ont
aussi avancé jusqu'à Koné au top c'est
assez plus c'était bien plus près que
soumis on peut le dire comme ça donc on
a vraiment l'impression que qu'ils
avancent bien sûr les autorités
ukrainiennes insistent clairement
ukrainienne
des victoires résistent repoussent mais
ils ont besoin de maintenir le moral des
Ukrainiens un conseiller au ministre de
l'Intérieur
ukrainien
beaucoup avec les journalistes a dit
aujourd'hui sera la journée la plus dure
mais oui évidemment on est dans une
situation où on comprend très bien que
c'est la capitale qui est visée et que
le but de Vladimir Poutine c'est un
changement de gouvernement pour le moins
on Ukraine le président
ukrainien a donc décrété la mobilisation
générale et le rappel des réservistes
dans toutes les régions du pays Guliver
comment est-ce que cela s'organise sur
le terrain
je ne sais pas exactement comment une
mobilisation militaire s'organise je
suis désolé jusqu'à hier c'était sur la
base du volontariats
à toutes les personnes capables de mener
des armes de participer à l'action
militaire de se présenter maintenant ce
n'est plus sur la base du volontariat si
je comprends bien cette obligatoire
quels sont les nouvelles consignes que
vous avez reçues de la part du
gouvernement ce matin
il y a cette couvre-feu je pense que
c'est de 10 heures du soir à 7h du matin
qui concerne tout le monde les
journalistes aussi il y a aussi beaucoup
de consignes de se méfier de ces
saboteurs potentiels de penser qu'il
peut y avoir déjà des agents russes dans
la ville donc de se comporter avec une
très grande méfiance et de coopérer un
maximum avec la police ukrainienne et je
ne sais pas exactement pourquoi mais de
ne pas porter du rouge et ils nous ont
dit de ne pas s'habiller en rouge ce qui
peut être un signe d'appartenance à un
groupe de saboters
autrement ils vont trouver un autre code
donc je ne sais pas exactement à quoi ça
sert autre consigne si vous voulez qui
vient d'en bas à la base beaucoup du
crédit a commencé à la dire et
maintenant il y a eu même des officiels
dans le gouvernement qui ont appelé aux
Ukrainiens de le faire demander aux
Russes de manifester voilà
appelle ton masse aux Russes de
manifester contre leur président contre
cette guerre on sait qu'ils l'ont fait à
Saint-Pétersbourg et à Moscou assez
nombreux par rapport aux manifestations
russes qu'on a l'habitude de voir mais
ils ont été aussi arrêtés par son
antenne par la police et dernière
question très rapidement Gulliver crack
comment les
Ukrainiens réagissent au soutien immense
de de
comment je vous dis je vous disais oui
pas de problème Gulliver je vous disais
comment réagissent les
Ukrainiens face au soutien de la société
civile un peu partout dans le monde on
l'a vu un peu plus tôt des
manifestations de soutien à Paris à
Berlin même au Japon en Australie
partout l'Ukraine est soutenu comment
réagissent à cela les Ukrainiens
surtout les Ukrainiens veulent voir une
action très concrète de la part des
alliés occidentales de l'Ukraine en
forme de sanction
ils apprécient bien sûr ces
manifestations mais c'est donc aussi qui
arrive cette mobilisation ce n'est pas
que cela passe
inaperçu ou sans appréciation mais ils
sentent que les sanctions ne sont je
pense que le sentiment général c'est que
les sanctions annoncées jusque là ne
vont pas assez loin et qu'il faut
vraiment que l'Ouest aille plus loin
pour contrer Vladimir Poutine voilà
Gulliver crack en direct de Kiev on a
ici à droite de l'image de l'écran des
images qui nous parviennent donc en
direct de Kiev on voit les dégâts
occasionnés par ces tirs de missiles
russes qui ont fait au moins trois
blessés 8 vous nous le disiez selon une
autre source Gulliver merci à vous ce
qu'on peut retenir